salah ça se règle ça ce paramètre ça se
voit là il ya des astuces pour gagner du
temps et faire des trucs et tout coule
avec ils étaient nombreux à me demander
mes réglages et tout et tout et tout bas
on va me parler on va en parler on va en
parler puisque vous voulez qu'on en
parle on va en parler après l'intro
comelade
[Musique]
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique moi encore je
suis ravi de vous retrouver une nouvelle
fois pour cette vidéo sur cette chaîne
qui parle d'image de photos de vidéos de
montage donc si c'est des sujets qui
vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner et à cliquer sur la petite
cloche tout ça tout ça
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un sujet
hyper important qui est le paramétrage
le réglage un petit peu de la caméra des
astuces qu'on va pouvoir voir que moi
j'utilise pour gagner du temps et de
l'efficacité dans mes shooting alors moi
je vous en parlais sur mon boitier sony
à 7,3 c'est exactement la même chose sur
quasiment tous les autres boîtiers sony
et sur les autres marques
on peut trouver des équivalences donc
même si vous n'êtes pas sûrs du sony ne
vous inquiétez pas vous pouvez quand
même faire quelque chose d'à peu près
6000 ha et puis juste avant de commencer
je vous mets aussi le lien vers mon
instinct où je mets des petits des
petites story des petites brode des
choses comme ça vous pouvez suivre un
petit peu l'envers du décor dont vous
pouvez aussi nous suivre sur un star son
mythique alors sur du sony tout est
paramétrable tous les boutons sont
assignables on peut se faire des
réglages personnalisés sur tous les
boutons
donc moi c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai
assigné ces boutons à des choses que
j'utilise régulièrement puisque les
menus sony sont quand même un petit peu
denses c'est pas hyper facile de s'y
retrouver donc dans un shoot c'est
compliqué donc ça c'est la première
chose à faire quand vous avez des
boutons paramétrables des boutons
assignables n'hésitez pas à vous en
servir parce que si vous avez un réglage
a modifié quand vous êtes en train de
tourner ça peut vite redevenir une
grosse angoisse parce que mémoriser tous
les menus c'est un petit peu long c'est
un petit peu compliqué surtout si en
plus on est dans le feu de l'action on
est un petit peu dans le stress le mieux
c'est d'avoir un bouton dédié à la
balance des blancs par exemple au mode
de focus au profil d'image et c'est donc
moi c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai assigné
toutes ces choses là a des boutons
spécifiques comme ça j'ai pas à rentrer
dans les menus quand je suis en train de
shooter alors en gros le bouton c'est un
ceux qui sont paramétrables
- j ai mis la balance des blancs parce
que bon la plupart du temps
j'utilise la balance des blancs
automatique et la plupart du temps elle
est largement suffisante c'est rare
qu'elle est vraiment merdé en
l'occurrence là c'est plutôt pas mal
mais il ya des situations dans
lesquelles
allez un petit peu plus approximatives
donc je veux quand même avoir ce bouton
de balance des blancs à proximité pour
pouvoir modifier éventuellement
directement si je me rends compte que
aulas et s'être orange ou c'est trop
bleu ou voilà trop chaud trop froid
c'est toujours important d'avoir sa
balance des blancs a porté le bouton
c'est de lui je lui est assignée aux
modes de focus au mode de mise au point
ça me permet de passer d'une mise au
point automatique à une mise au point
manuelle pareil souvent l'autofocus
marche relativement bien mais il ya des
situations dans lesquelles ça fout un
petit peu la merde alors ces pratiques
de pouvoir passer directement en manuel
surtout quand on n'a pas un petit bouton
sur l'objectif le 16 35 puis il a un
petit look et pour passer de la mise au
point automatique à la mise au point
manuelle mais c'est pas le cas de tous
les objectifs donc pour le coup je me
suis mis aussi sur un bouton
personnalisable le mode de mise au point
sur les molettes rien de fou fou un la
molette de devancer l'ouverture la
molette de l'ariège c'est le shooter's
peas et la petite molette de façade
ça va être mais iso et c'est un des gros
plus que je vois par rapport à la 6400
par exemple c'est à dire que je vais
avoir mes trois monts triptyque
d'exposition qui va être accessible
directement sur chaque molette et sans
avoir à rentrer dans un menu particulier
ça va très vite c'est hyper pratique sur
la molette aussi justement on a des
possibilités d'assigner en cliquant sur
chaque axe de la molette sur un menu
ben là encore j'ai pas toutes utilisées
puisque j'ai pas forcément l'utilité
mais sur le clic du bas j'ai ajouté les
profils d'image parce que la plupart du
temps je shoote sur un profil h et le g2
qui me convient vraiment que je trouve
hyper souple sur du reportage qui
vraiment pratique
mais il ya des fois où je suis obligé de
shooter sans profil d'image parce que
c'est une commande d'un client par
exemple on veut du neutre on veut du
rapide on veut pas de colle au derrière
donc je fais directement là dessus ce
bouton me permet de switcher d'un profil
à un autre mais on pourra aussi passer
sur du log sur des choses comme ça sans
avoir pareil à rentrer dans les menus
est allé chercher le menu profil d'image
l'ag ce bouton là qui est dédié et c'est
à peu près tous les raccourcis que je me
suis créé sur ses boutons
personnalisables mais il ya un truc
encore plus cool
ce sont les modes personnalisable alors
sur le dessus de l'appareil vous avez
une molette avec les menus classiques on
va voir les différents modes on va voir
le mode automatique on va avoir la
priorité à l'ouverture la priorité au
jeu torspyd le ralenti que je ne vous
conseille pas d'ailleurs n'ont pas une
bonne opération à mon avis le mode vidéo
tout ça tout ça bon et sur cette molette
vous avez un menu 1 et 2 alors je vais
pas vous refaire un truc qu'on a vu dans
plein de vidéos déjà si vous savez pas
ce que c'est je vais vous expliquer très
rapidement à quoi ça correspond mais on
va plutôt s'intéresser nous à ce que moi
j'ai mis dedans donc ces deux modes 1 et
2 ça va être des modes que vous allez
personnalisée c'est à dire que vous
allez définir un chanteur speed vous
avez définir une ouverture des iso un
profil d'image tout un tas de réglages
qui vont être enregistrés et que vous
allez pouvoir ressortir simplement en
tournant la molette et ça gros gros gros
gain de temps vraiment donc ce que j'ai
fait moi c'est que sur le mode 1
je me suis fait un mode vitesse réelle
c'est à dire que je filme à 25 images
par seconde
schroeder speed 1 50e les iso au plus
bas sage a juste en fonction de la scène
et en 4k typiquement c'est le mode que
j'utilise la exactement là en train de
filmer puisque j'ai pas de ralenti à
faire dessus je veux la meilleure image
et la meilleure qualité possible c'est
mon mode 1 et bien sûr j'utilise un
profil d'image
en effet le g2 pour mémoriser ça c'est
très simple il suffit d'aller dans le
menu pour cette fois ya fallait rentrer
au moins une fois voilà pour paramétrer
le truc on va d'abord faire tous les
paramétrages tous les réglages en france
mais dès le départ
en mode vidéo ensuite on va régler le
shooter's pile la 4k le nombre d'image
par seconde etc etc
puis on va dans le menu dans les menus
mémoire et on va
enregistré dans l'ain placement tout
simplement voilà comme ça
ensuite le mode 2 bat tout simplement je
me suis fait un mode slow mots en mode
pour les ralentis dans qu'il est
paramétré à 100 l'image par seconde il
est bien sûr en full hd en 1080p ce que
le 7 3 ne permet pas de faire le 4k à
cette cadence là j'ai le même profil
d'image j'ai par contre un minimum de 1
200e pour le shooteur puisqu'on au
ralenti donc c'est la règle et 180
degrés tout ça et mes ciseaux sont au
plus bas je les ajuste en fonction de la
scène en fonction de l'éclairage qui va
y avoir puisque j'ai ma petite molette
des iso qui me permet d'ajuster sa hyper
rapidement et j'ai envie de dire on peut
même encore aller plus loin puisque dans
chacun de ces modes on va avoir quatre
possibilités d'enregistrement de
réglages différents
alors je vous encourage pas à tous les
remplir parce que là encore s'il faut
mémoriser à quoi correspondent chaque
emplacement la 1 et 2 pour moi c'est
bien dans le feu de l'action
ça va vite c'est pas très compliqué mais
on peut avoir
glageon mettons de balance des blancs
est spécial pour la soirée par exemple
pour les faible luminosité on peut
utiliser encore un profil d'image
différents par exemple pour la faible
luminosité aussi mais ne remplissez pas
tout parce que potentiellement vous
allez vous y perdre et ça risque de
coincer un petit peu donc à la limite
les deux modes et puis à l'intérieur
éventuellement une variation par rapport
la musique et tous les hits alors par
exemple ou à la balance des blancs ou
des choses comme ça mais on n'allait pas
trop loin donc vous mettre huit modes
différents parce que on va revenir en
fait au problème initial qui est qu'il
ya trop de menus trop de choix dans la
plupart des appareils et que nous ce
qu'on veut c'est allé vite sur le moment
et pas perdre de temps et pas se
stresser parce que à il est où ce
réglage je trouve plus alia j'ai
raté mon truc voilà ça y est c'est fini
l'idée c'est ça c'est vraiment là pour
le coup dans mon réglage non paramétrage
c'est grosso modo de pouvoir passer
rapidement du slow mots à la vitesse
réelle puisque de toute façon avec tous
les boutons personnalisables dont je
vous ai parlé au début mais j'ai tous
mes petits réglages de finition qui sont
accessibles aux doigts directement sur
un bouton donc voilà les deux gros mode
plus le paramétrage des boutons on est
assez large en terme de variété de ce
qu'on va pouvoir shooter et on va être
relativement à l'aise quand même faut
dire ce qui est et voilà les amis c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui on a fait le tour
un petit peu de ce paramétrage de
caméras ici j'espère que c'est des
conseils qui vous aideront et qui vous
permettront d'être plus sereins sur
tournage si cette vidéo vous a plu comme
d'habitude on n'hésite pas à mettre le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo si vous n'êtes
pas déjà abonné vous pouvez le faire
vous pouvez activer la cloche pouvait me
donner un commentaire aussi vous vos
paramétrages customiser vos réglages de
caméras parce que bah c'est valable pour
moi ici mais c'est différent pour tout
le monde l'ergonomie 1 c'est la même
pour personne donc pour le coup ça peut
être intéressant d'en discuter en
commentaire et puis ben moi je vous dis
comme d'habitude un rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo et
vous êtes quasiment 250 à vous êtes
inscrits à la formation sur fight que je
sorte il aya il ya quelques semaines c
juste fou quoi et vos retours les notes
et ou ccc canon quand ça fait hyper
plaisir donc
waouh c'est c'est quand même hyper cool
c'est quand même hyper cool et merci
beaucoup d'amis je suis vraiment hyper
content de vous avoir aidé à ce niveau
là et vous apprendre des trucs ça me
fait super plaisir
donc voilà si vous n'êtes pas encore
allé pouvait aller jeter un oeil le lien
il est dans la description